[Music]
now here you are the best spaghetti in a
town
[Music]
that famous scene is from the disney
animated classic
lady and the [ __ ] and the spaghetti
those two were sharing
is a classic two one of the original
shapes of italian pasta
of course from ears to elbows to bow
ties
pasta comes in plenty of other forms but
one enthusiastic eater thought that list
wasn't complete
dan paschman host of the award-winning
sportful podcast
challenged himself to create an all-new
perfect pasta
shape and after a three-year journey
he's got the water boiling and
is ready to put it to the test nancy
chen has his story
inside this warehouse in upstate new
york more than
four thousand miles away from the
cucinas of italy
what's cooking is perhaps the biggest
thing in pasta
since a noodle took to sauce or at least
that's what dan paschman
is hoping this right here is the perfect
pasta shake
perfect is a strong word nancy i'm not
going to go that far but i will say that
it is one of the greatest pasta shapes
of all time
hashman is the creator and host of the
sportful
a food podcast he created after getting
laid off from his job and radio
we are setting out to invent a new pasta
shake and actually get it made
and actually sell it on it he started a
five-part
series called mission impossible his
crusade to engineer a new pasta shape
hoping to push aside his least favorite
noodle
dan what's wrong with spaghetti
oh how much time do you have nancy uh i
mean
look spaghetti is fine i'll eat any
pasta you put in front of me if i'm
hungry
but it's just a tube it doesn't do very
much
and i just think that we can do better
paschman's quest started at the source
itself with a trip to north dakota
home to most of the country's wheat for
pasta i learned all about the flowers
the semolina
it's a little more expensive but it
makes pasta with more flavor
there was also plenty of research for
the pashmin family as
pasta became the meal du jour all
leading to him not only inventing a new
shape
but new words sasebility tooth sync
ability and forkability yes
did you make those words up i did yes i
come up with these three metrics by
which i
judge all pasta shapes so fork ability
which is how easy is it to get it on
your fork and keep it there
sauce ability how readily does sauce
adhere and
tooth sync ability which is how
satisfying is it to sink your teeth into
it
and a lot of pasta shapes are great at
one or two of these three things
but very few nail all three there's a
lot of science to this it seems
there is there's science and
pseudoscience
even armed with its own vocabulary dan's
idea quickly proved more difficult than
he ever imagined
i finally get a pasta diet company to
take me seriously i get a company who'll
make the pasta i get the materials for
the dye
then the shape i've conceived turns out
to be physically impossible
i wanted this combination of mafalda and
bucatini so it would have a tube
component and a ruffle component but the
dope only painted it's clear as pasta
had taken over dan paschman's life
as he sucked nearly ten thousand dollars
of his own money into the project
his family along for the ride i was
sketching
pasta shapes on graph paper at my
daughter's soccer practice
lying awake at night thinking about
pasta shapes but thousands of pasta
pieces later those sketches became the
real deal
here at this fellini pasta factory in
new york's hudson valley
where the cascatelli was finally born it
means waterfall
in italian
[Music]
cashman's pasta with a longer cut than
most short shapes
so it's easier to grab with a fork a
bugattini half tube with ruffles to
create what he calls
a sauce trough and something that is
rare in pasta
you have these ruffles at a 90 degree
angle that means that whatever direction
you bite from you're going to get
resistance
you're going to stick your teeth into it
examining the functionality of macaroni
may be new to dan
but those who know pasta know what the
perfect bite
comes down to you know it's all about
pairing the particular
shape with the particular sauce it's
definitely about both yes
it's the whole package it's like the
marriage of the two a perfect pairing
just like angie rito and scott
tassinelli the husband and wife team
behind treasured new york city italian
restaurant
don angie okay first bites in what do
you think
i like the texture of it a lot i think
it's uh
it holds the sauce really well
definitely sticks to the fork really
well
right this feels like a very substantial
meal
i gave it a thumbs up i think it's
really good does it win your endorsement
no i want to create a pasta shape
while pashman's new noodle fared well
with these chefs
we wanted to take it to someone else who
has strong opinions on food and
isn't afraid to share them i know the
pasta because i cook
all my life an italian grandmother
you can receive my house i because all
the pasta
maria gia lanella came to the united
states in 1961 from italy
she now works at inoteca maria on staten
island
most people here call her nona maria
nona meaning grandmother
because she cooks for everyone as if
they were part of her family
including me okay first bite good
no beautiful so it gets the nano seal of
approval
yeah see
perhaps no better affirmation that
paschman's mission impossible
to come up with his very own pallet
pleasing shape
was possible after all what's your dream
with all of this
what if this becomes a pasta shape that
just everybody knows and it's on
restaurant
menus and you can buy it in stores and
i could tell people i invented a pasta
shape and my family will be proud of me
and it will make people happy if that
happens i will be very satisfied
for cbs this morning saturday nancy chen
new york now if you can only make it
without the
calories and carb content dan's first
batch of cascatelli sold out within
two hours of being available online all
3 700 boxes but don't worry
more has been made and you can try it by
ordering the pasta from cephalini's
website how about that never did you
think pasta shapes could be that
fascinating but
nancy made it so interesting yeah think
about that
i guess we take it home and taste it